[Music]
here's something you might not have
thought of that harvey could cause
serious damage to the economy as the
heavy rains continue to hammer texas
this morning the gulf coast is
responsible for more than 45 percent of
u.s oil refining capabilities the storm
has taken dozens of production platforms
offline and that will have a significant
effect on the economy of texas and gas
prices at your house cbs news business
analyst jill schlesinger joins us at the
table to discuss hey jill good morning
officials say that 20 percent of
production is now down because of the
storm and that normally means doesn't
mean your gas prices are going down no
and it's especially significant if you
live in the south the southeast and the
mid-atlantic we have some projections
that prices could go up by as much as 15
cents per gallon i guess that may be the
saving grace is that in that area
especially in texas and the southeast
they have been paying lower than the
national average right now 210 to 220 a
gallon but this is likely to go up when
these events occur they are usually very
severe but short-lived so we're hopeful
for that the rest of the country you're
going to see prices drift up not nearly
as much again as the south the southeast
and the mid-atlantic when you say short
live what do you mean uh weeks not
months that's what i mean so hopefully
it's weeks and and that should be again
like a moment it's not going to feel
good if you live down there though
obviously does history tell us that's
the case from say katrina yes because
what happens is two things as we know
the refineries come offline right they
have to do that prior to the storm to be
safe they do it during the storm and in
the aftermath they can't afford to take
the risk of having something really bad
happen on a platform right so all of
that will come offline but it will
usually come back up in weeks some
refineries had during katrina were off
for months but that was the minority not
the majority and we're looking now at
what some of these people who are
leaving their homes
can start to anticipate when they try to
recover only 15 percent of homes in that
county have federal flood insurance so
affording to rebuild may ultimately come
down to the u.s taxpayer right
absolutely and i know that we've talked
on the show already about how there were
some ideas about cutting fema's budget
but i don't think that's going to happen
in the midst of this storm and as you
said look federal flood insurance is a
wonderful program but number one you
have to be a designated flood zone
participant you have to live there then
you have to actually buy the insurance
if you have a mortgage usually your
lender will force you to get it but if
you've already paid off your mortgage
you may have let that bill go and you're
not covered and what's really important
here is most homeowners coverage regular
homeowners coverage you cover that will
not cover that so it'll cover if a tree
falls through your roof it will cover it
but from rising water you're not covered
that's terribly important keep great
records during this time nothing worse
than paying all that money for insurance
and then you go to make a claim they go
oh sorry not covered yes but i do
believe that the federal government will
step in here that's what has happened
that's what happened in sandy and
katrina if you are covered will they
cover the whole thing or just a portion
uh well it's really normal let's be
clear if you are affected by this what
you must do is keep copious records a
list i know it don't give me the face
i'm sorry but you have to this is what
you have to do because you know what
you've got to build a case what i
learned after living through sandy
myself was the more information you had
the better lots of record keeping please
write a list of everything you think is
damaged right now a lot of pictures lots
of photos pictures
cause right now you're trying to save
your life but you also need to take
pictures to document them absolutely all
right joe thank you thanks